[Music]
more bad news for Mark Harmon and NCIS
fan I'm really sorry Gibbs
the franchise is losing another original
cast member you okay pauley perrette
confirmed on Twitter Wednesday that
she's exiting the hit CBS show after 15
seasons tweeting there have been all
kinds of false rumors as to why no I
don't have a skincare line and to know
my network and show are not mad at me
the fake stories did you pot you're
leaving NCIS and because of a skincare
line like you know I die it's just been
it's so frustrating
CBS my network and and NCIS my show is
all like mad at me because it was crazy
and I'm like okay this could affect my
job and my reputation Barret who plays
Abby Sciuto went on to explain that she
actually made the decision to walk away
sometime last year adding I hope
everyone will love and enjoy everything
Abby not only for the rest of this
season but for everything she has given
all of us for 16 years after Polly's
announcement CBS released this statement
to et while it's never easy saying
goodbye to a beloved actress and
character we respect her decision to
leave at the end of the season I'm like
the biggest and she is fine I think it's
a greatest show ever in December 2016
she opened up to ET about her success on
the show it's been the number one drama
in the world for years and years and
years and like at some point I think
it's last year they had said that like
at any given moment there's 59 million
people watching in DC I asked somewhere
on the planet mm-hmm so no I can't go to
it